on va parler à présent de sécurité
routière avec Nicolas corrobelly hein je
le disais vous êtes le directeur
régional Île-de-France de l'association
Prévention Routière on parlait tout à
l'heure de cette association et des
actions qui sont déployées on va parler
aussi un de ces derniers chiffres de la
sécurité routière qui ont été révélés il
y a 2 semaines déjà une première
tendance à vendre parler de
l'augmentation de la mort des cyclistes
en 2022 si on prend l'année de référence
qui est 2019 il y a une augmentation en
2002 en 2022 pardon d'un point de vue
global sur la mortalité on est plutôt
sur des des statistiques stables en
France on parle d'une augmentation
seulement de 0,5% 3260 décès en 2022
est-ce qu'en Île-de-France on est sur la
même tendance et on est sur la même
tendance en Île-de-France et
3260 décès en France c'est il y a une
augmentation par rapport à 2019 que
l'année de référence et il y avait un
engagement du gouvernement de d'amener
le nombre de morts en 2020 à
2000 personnes sur les routes 2020 c'est
l'année covid et même cette année où on
a été freiné dans nos déplacements où il
y a eu des périodes de restriction on
n'a pas atteint ce chiffre de 2000
personnes tuées sur les routes en France
on était autour de 2500 morts voilà donc
une année de référence puisqu'on ne
compte pas les deux années qu'au lieu en
tout cas on les compte mais
21 et même le début de 2022 où il y
avait des restrictions encore sur les
sur les sur les déplacements donc cette
augmentation de 0,5% elle est à corréler
avec le début de l'année 2022 donc ça
c'est pour les chiffres global point de
vue des automobilistes on est plutôt sur
une tendance à la baisse même oui on est
sur une tendance à la baisse sur les sur
les automobilistes et par contre une
tendance à la hausse sur les usagers
vulnérables
usagers vulnérable et on parle notamment
et c'est l'objet de notre interview de
l'augmentation de la mortalité chez les
cyclistes c'est un phénomène aussi qui
s'observe chez les utilisateurs de
trottinette on aura l'occasion d'en
parler
propose de 30% au niveau de la France au
niveau national et pour la deuxième
année consécutive la barre des 200 morts
a été franchie au niveau de la mortalité
des des cyclistes si on regarde les
chiffres au niveau foncilien c'est 9
personnes qui ont perdu la vie en vélo
en 2022 comment on explique cette hausse
il y a de plus en plus d'utilisateurs de
vélo depuis justement le covid-19
peut-être avec eux aussi cet impact
écologique en ce moment il y a eu un
changement des habitudes des français
sur sur le déplacement et 2020 2021 il y
a eu un report de la part modale et
d'augmentation du nombre de cyclistes
nous c'est quelque chose qu'on a qu'on a
identifié tout de suite à la à
l'association et on a vu aussi des gens
ressortir des vélos qui étaient mal
entretenus ou qui était ou des personnes
qui n'avaient pas fait de vélo depuis
longtemps que se remettre à faire du
vélo peut-être un manque de vigilance de
ces personnes là en manque il y a un
manque de vigilance il y a une
infrastructure qui est en train de de
s'adapter aussi à ce nouveau mode de
déplacement ou la visiteurs il y a un
plan de développement sur Saint-Quentin
des pistes cyclable donc il faut que
chacun trouve sa place dans dans ces ce
dans la route et sur la sur la rue pour
que chacun puisse circuler librement
selon le mode de déplacement qu'il a
choisi
qui a des efforts qui sont faits par les
collectivités en matière de vélo on
parle de plus en plus de ce projet de
RER vélo aussi au niveau qui est porté
par la région qui va se déployer et qui
nous est l'ossature de notre schéma
directeur cyclable j'ai rappelé c'est 37
millions d'euros ça veut dire que c'est
600 km à terme d'itinéraires recyclables
tout l'enjeu vous l'avez dit c'est le
partage de l'espace public il faut qu'on
arrive à faire en sorte que les
différents acteurs de la route que les
différentes mobilités les différents
modes de déplacement arrivent à
cohabiter entre eux les chiffres que
vous avez donné je j'ai pas toutes les
explications mais c'est vrai que
proportionnellement j'imagine qu'on doit
avoir un petit peu plus d'accident quand
on a un petit peu plus aussi
d'utilisateurs je trouve que c'est non
pour les accident attention il faut les
traiter mais c'est une bonne chose de
voir que les comportements évoluent et
que on va de plus en plus vers les modes
actifs et les mobilités douces moi je
vous prends juste un chiffre parce que
je l'ai à l'esprit et que il m'a été
communiqué il y a très peu de temps je
répondais à mes collègues merde de 50
ans sur le taux d'accidentologie sur le
service de trottinette de
l'agglomération en un an avec plus d'un
million trois de trajet et 71000
utilisateurs on a fait 5 accidents qui
ont concerné et impliqué des
trottinettes tir
c'est rien c'est rien alors ça reste
cinq accidents de trop mais
proportionnellement à ce qu'on peut voir
sur d'autres collectivités ça montre que
tout est aussi à faire d'organisation de
la micromobilité et notamment aussi de
l'usage du vélo donc en tout cas il faut
continuer les efforts sont à faire et je
crois que les infrastructures vous
l'avez dit aussi les infrastructures
sont vraiment la priorité tout à fait
juste avant de parler des trottinettes
si on regarde un peu plus précisément
les chiffres sur les cyclistes c'est
d'ailleurs dans les Yvelines au niveau
francilien qui a eu plus de morts en
vélo en 2022 3 décès dans le département
et il y a d'ailleurs plus de victimes en
grande couronne que sur Paris il y a eu
un décès à Paris l'an passé ça aussi
comment l'explique c'est que les
utilisateurs à Paris ont peut-être un
peu plus l'habitude d'utiliser le vélo
dans un on va dire dans un environnement
où il y a un peu plus de circulation
aussi
je pense que les les vitesses de
déplacement des véhicules sont Paris
sont plus faibles et donc nous on c'est
quelque chose qu'on qu'on comporte sur
sur les villes on descendre villes
apaisées à 30 km/h des zones de
rencontre c'est c'est des moments où on
transforme des accidents qui sont des
accidents mortels en des accidents qui
sont des accidents corporels et où voilà
à un piéton la différence entre un
piéton à 50 km/h un piéton à 30 km/h
c'est la différence entre un tuyau sur
la route et
quelqu'un qui qui malheureusement va
être blessé mais va se remettre de cet
accident alors le trophée que je voulais
aborder avec vous je suis des
trottinettes électriques il y a eu 600
blessés graves en France en 2022 34 trop
de citer trottinettiste qui sont décédés
en 2022 il y a l'Académie de médecine
notamment qui demande une réglementation
plus stricte en la matière est-ce que
vous êtes du même avis pour aller
justement vers moins d'accidents alors
nous au sein de l'association d'un
conseil médical qui a étudié cette
question et qui nous a fait remonter
aussi un certain nombre d'informations
que des différents hôpitaux et ce qui
nous dit c'est que aujourd'hui on se on
a de plus en plus de
traumatismes crâniens et de d'écrasement
de la face du au trottinette électrique
c'est ça s'explique par cet engin qui a
un engin ou le centre de gravité est
très bas et on fait très facilement un
soleil quand on a une aspérité sur la
route quand on rencontre un obstacle et
donc c'est la phase qui prend qui est
souvent parce qu'on n'a pas le réflexe
de forcément de mettre les mains et de
qui sont occupés par le guidon et donc
de ce de se protéger nous
le développement de la trottinette
électrique qu'on a c'est une mesure
qu'on a porté à l'occasion des
présidentielles on a toujours défendu le
fait qu'il fallait obliger les personnes
qui utilisent cette trottinette
électrique apporter un casque et même ce
qu'on nous c'est que
au-delà du casque il y a ces espèces de
casque intégraux là qui protège aussi la
face parce que et la mâchoire parce
qu'on a des des traumatismes sur sur la
mâchoire donc on a réglementé on sait
maintenant où doit rouler les
trottinettes électriques toutes ces
zones de flou dans au début sur le
développement de la trottinette
électrique on sait maintenant où elles
doivent rouler je pense que il faut
maintenant agir sur sur l'usager que je
me disais tout à l'heure c'est les
usagers vulnérables ils ont pas de
carrosserie c'est
voilà il faut il faut prendre des
mesures pour pour les personnes qui
utilisent la trottinette et il faut
qu'on fasse rentrer la trottinette
électrique comme un véritable mode de
déplacement parce que
je pense qu'il y a encore un côté
utilisation un peu fun de la trottinette
électrique et une taille de sensibiliser
c'est aussi le rôle on l'a compris de
votre association faire un travail
auprès aussi des pouvoirs publics pour
pouvoir peut-être évolution
on porte ça on l'a porté pendant les
présidentielles on est
et on met en place des actions de
prévention sur la trottinette électrique
sur
sur des entreprises qui s'équipent
aujourd'hui de trottinette électrique
mais qui veulent que leur salarié une
sensibilisation avant et on avait un
programme
c2eux c'est appelé mobiprox qui qui
faisait de la sensibilisation sur la
trottinette électrique très rapidement
leur rôle est essentiel sur la
prévention il y a aussi le rôle que
peuvent jouer les collectivités qui
décident de déployer ce type de service
parce qu'il y a effectivement la loi
mais nous on a décidé d'aller beaucoup
plus loin je rappelle que sur
Saint-Quentin on a des engins dont la
vitesse est bridée à 20 km/h qu'on a
exigé dans notre appel à candidature qui
a un casque intégré aux trottinette donc
tout ça ce sont des choses que les
collectivités peuvent décider notre
trottinette sont également immatriculées
donc il y a aussi un élan en termes de
sécurité à donner quand on souhaite
lancer ce type de projet merci en tout
cas d'être venu parler de ce sujet je
rappelle que vous êtes le directeur
régional d'Île-de-France Île-de-France
de l'association Prévention Routière